hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean science
fiction action film called Jung e
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is set in the near
post-apocalyptic future where the sea
levels have risen due to Rapid climate
change this has made the earth mostly
uninhabitable so a group of scientists
ventured into space to find a solution
after years of research they built 80
large shelters on the Earths and Moon's
orbital Plains then for the next few
decades 90 percent of the human
population slowly relocated there as for
the remaining 10 percent they were
against the plan and thus decided to
remain on Earth for the first few years
everyone lived peacefully but then the
citizens of some shelters formed a
radical group known as the Adrian
Republic they began attacking the other
shelter inhabitants the Adrian Republic
wanted to absorb all the power for
themselves and eliminate anyone who came
in their way fortunately the remaining
humans formed an Allied Force resulting
in decades of brutal Warfare in the
first scene we are introduced to Captain
Yan Jung Yi a brave mercenary of the
Allied Forces she has led her team to
countless successful missions against
the Adrian Republic and and is still
going strong one day she is seen
valiantly fighting her way through an
army of enemy mechanoids however during
the battle she gets shot in the fingers
which reveals that she is actually a
robot even Captain Yun didn't know about
this leaving her in utter disbelief the
next second she gets deactivated and the
whole setup is shown to be a virtual
fighting simulation it's then revealed
that the robot is actually an AI version
of Captain Yoon as she has been in a
coma for 35 years three minutes in and
we've already got enough twists for
three shy mlms Captain young got fatally
wounded during a battle but since she
was the best fighter the Allies had to
offer they are trying to bring her back
again afterwards several researchers and
scientists approached the robot and run
some Diagnostics they are from a tech
company called chronoid shortly after Dr
Yan SEO Hyun the team leader of the
research project titled Jung e enters
the simulation room she is actually the
daughter of Captain Yoon and her main
objective is to memorialize her mother
as a war hero rather than a failure so
she along with many other researchers at
chronoid have copied Captain yon's brain
data to install them into Android bodies
naming the project Zhang e later at a
meeting with the higher-ups chronoid
director Kim sang Hoon explains that
through the simulations of Captain
yoon's final failed Mission they have
been trying to extract combat memory
data that could be used to develop an
exceptional AI however in every
simulation the robot fails for some
unknown reason maybe because they're
extracting the data from a mission where
she failed as a result the higher-ups
are dissatisfied with the Jung e project
and instead makes snarky remarks about
how Captain young could have ended the
decade-long war between the Adrian
Republic and the Allied Forces if she
had completed her last mission after the
meeting director Kim informs xyo Hyun
that the higher-ups have agreed to
Greenlight the project provided that the
AI passes the simulation test Kim comes
off as the hilarious sidekick who
believes in the jungi project and AIDS
SEO Hyun all the way later a new staff
member Jae kyung Sparks a conversation
with xiaohyun after running some
Diagnostics on an Android he mentions
that he is a big fan of Captain Yoon and
considers her a superhero after a while
SEO Hyun reveals that the only reason
her mother became a mercenary was to pay
for her treatments as xiaohyun had
suffered from cancer when she was a
child however on the day of her surgery
which was successful Captain young had
been called on a mission this proved to
be her last one which left her in a
critical condition and eventually a coma
in the present xiaohyun finished his
work and goes to take her ethics test
this is a requirement for all chronoid
employees which helps to differentiate
robots from humans on the way she
remembers the last time she had seen her
mother the two had hugged and rubbed
each other's cheeks right before SEO
hyun's surgery afterwards she goes to
her doctor for a normal body checkup
when the X-ray scans her out
unfortunately it is revealed that SEO
hyun's Childhood cancer has returned and
now she only has three months left to
live the doctor informs her that her
best course of action will be to copy
and transfer her brain data to a
prosthetic body he then proceeds to
explain the different categories of the
bodies starting with an expensive type a
prosthetic body which will grant her
equal human rights by the government he
also explains that if she chooses to opt
for the less expensive type B the
government will be allowed to access her
brain's data and it's some fundamental
human rights like marriage freedom of
movement and adoption will be prohibited
the last option being type c which the
government will provide for free however
certain companies will be permitted to
exploit her brain data and can make
clones out of it in other words type c
is basically signing up for tick tock
after their session ciohyan asks to see
her mother and it turns out that the
doctor is also an Android the scene then
cuts to a flashback from when SEO hyung
is Young she recalls learning that her
mother did survive the mission but is
now in critical condition the chronoid
team visitsiohyan and her grandmother
where they manage to convince to pay for
SEO hyun's schooling and living expenses
in exchange for turning Captain Yan's
body to a type c process aesthetic body
eventually her grandmother agrees to the
condition the movie then cuts to the
present where xio Hyun visits her mother
and sees her all wrinkled and old still
in a coma a few days later at chronoid
the AI model number 18 is activated and
is ready for the simulation however this
time director Kim suggests that they do
something different so he orders the
researchers to shoot the Android in the
leg once the simulation starts the
Android has a difficult time fighting
back and is overpowered by the enemy
robots but before they end the test all
of a sudden a new area of the artificial
brain indicated by yellow strobes of
light is activated and the Jung e robot
fights back with full force the entire
project members are thrilled with this
breakthrough especially Kim so the next
day the team heads to the main chronoid
HQ to inform the company chairman of
this advancement turns out all we had to
do was piss him off sir however once
there they are approached by the new
product development manager who informs
them that the chairman is on a available
Kim is enraged and is confused as to why
a military-based company would need a
product Department the manager however
makes light of Kim's anger and laughs at
him before leaving after the
disappointing attempt the Jung e team
head back to the chronoid lab where the
newly made brains are now ready to be
simulated there a staff member informs
Kim that the chairman is waiting in his
office as they enter Kim is suddenly
deactivated and in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that he is
actually the first prototype created by
the chairman himself meanwhile ciohyun
explains their amazing breakthrough to
the chairman but he isn't impressed he
instead announces that a peace treaty
between the Adrian Republic and the
Allied Forces is underway and that the
Civil War is now going to end since the
combat AIS will not be needed anymore
the manager orders xiaohian to Halt the
Jung e project the hard work will not go
in vain however as the ai's collected
data will be used in household work the
chairman also reveals that he will
destroy Kim once everything is wrapped
up this breaks heart as she has
dedicated almost all her life to
bringing her mother back in the next
scene the group continues with the jungi
project to give it a proper conclusion
however during the simulations director
Kim is angry and upset that the AI keeps
on failing at the same time and location
he demands an arm to be cut off to
activate the yellow part of the brain
but to no avail since shooting the AI in
the leg previously helped activate it
Kim heads inside the laboratory and
opens fire into the AI making her scream
in pain the sight horrifies xiaohian and
when she cannot stand it any longer she
takes control over the AI and shuts it
down when she refuses to turn it back on
and enraged Kim points a gun to her head
this results in a heated confrontation
between the two but fortunately they are
interrupted by a staff member who
informs Kim that the chairman is waiting
for him after the scary encounter
ciohyun finds out that one of the Jung
eais has been mysteriously taken by the
new employee Jack hyung wasting no time
she visits his room only to discover
that the the AI is fully stripped
horrified so he uncovers her mom's body
and immediately pins Jack young against
the wall gasping for air he explains
that he got orders straight from the
headquarters to test out the sexual
capabilities of the Jung e models as
they can make tons of money if marketed
this enrages xiaohian even more how
could you be so depraved these are for
sex they're for killing people and she
tries to choke Jack young but right then
she remembers that her mother's brain is
Type C which can be used for any company
and products disheartening her later
xiaohian runs into director Kim who is
also upset about the discontinuation of
the jungi project before leaving he
informs her that the team is allowed one
more simulation test if they cannot come
up with anything conclusive all of their
hard work and research will go down the
drain in the next scene sio Hyun goes
into the AI lab and activates a Jung e
model that Kim had previously laid waste
upon she is critically wounded and the
best option would be to terminate her
the AI also accepts her fate but before
Cohen deactivates it the yellow part of
the brain suddenly appears and the AI
shockingly inquires about her daughter
then she shows human emotions and
recalls seeing her daughter for the last
time before going into battle hearing
this tears stream down xiaohian's face
and she informs the AI that her
daughter's surgery was a success and
that she is in remission for cancer the
AI is relieved and she also remembers
that xiaohian had given her a doll right
before her surgery currently she has
lost the doll and is very upset about it
SEO Hyun puts two and two together and
realizes that all the Jung e AIS had
failed in the simulation after spotting
the doll near them which distracted them
from the battle later xiaohian
deactivates the robot and begins to cry
profusely after talking to her mother in
an emotional manner which means that its
brain cloning is almost perfect so the
next day before the simulation xiaohyun
hooks the jungi AI up by herself after
everyone leaves the room she finds out
that the yellow part of the ai's brain
is actually the memory of her daughter
this was the only reason she was failing
the challenges in the simulation now
that SEO Hyun knows about the cause she
deletes it permanently shortly after the
test begins and everyone is upset as it
is their last one as expected the AI
gets shot at the same time and falls to
the ground failing the simulation test
once again after the test ends Jake
young notices that this specific AI test
result is quite odd but Kim ignores him
and leaves the room unhappy followed by
xiaohian however shortly after Kim
smells that something fishy is going on
and so he returns back into the lab to
double check the simulation to his shock
it's revealed that the Jung e model
didn't get shot but rather faked it and
pretended to deactivate Kim immediately
locks the place down and initiates an
emergency lockdown meanwhile the guards
who are escorting the Jung e AI back to
her chamber are confused by the alarm
taking advantage of the distraction she
disarms them and runs away when Kim gets
to know of this he activates all the
combat AI prototypes to find and
terminate Jung e elsewhere xiaohian
deletes all of her mother's brain data
so that it can never be cloned again in
the next scene Jung e enters a room full
of her clones taking her by surprise the
bad guys also arrive and try to take her
down but the legendary Captain Jan's AI
is simply too much for them to handle
however when the combat AIS keep on
coming in numbers xiaohyun rushes to the
room to help her mom at an opportune
moment she transfers her brain into one
of the newer combat ai's models
deceiving everyone the mother daughter
then flee in a futuristic skyrail train
but Kim is not going to let them get
away so easily he follows them there and
even shoots yohion in the shoulder
Furious Jung e fights Kim and shoots him
in the eye making him realize that he is
also in fact an AI the two then start
tussling with all their might and to
make matters worse the AI police also
show up in open fire at this point it
appears as if all hope is lost but when
jungi notices her injured daughter
trembling on the floor She gains renewed
motivation she turns into a cold-hearted
killer and takes on the bad guys one by
one eventually Kim is thrown from the
train and all the other robots are also
defeated afterwards jungi begins to help
sio Hyun but the latter begs her to
leave as she hears the police sirens in
the distance xiaohian tearfully claims
that the AI is free now and tells her to
run away and live her life the way she
wants jungi reluctantly agrees and she
gives her daughter a final hug the two
also rub their cheeks just like they
used to when syokian was a kid it is
then revealed that the AI has not
forgotten about her real identity as
Captain Yoon Jung Yi xio Hyun calls the
AI mother and wishes her luck before she
escapes the AI turns back and says
the movie then ends with xiaohian slowly
succumbing to her injuries while the AI
gazes at a mountain range and Embraces
the view subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watch teaching